[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de vie pour
aujourd'hui j'ai le grand bonheur la
grand le grand plaisir de recevoir
Arthur Loisel Arthur Loisel il est
yvelinois originaire de Versailles et
c'est un auteur acteur qui a une belle
actualité bien remplie dont nous allons
parler ensemble Arthur Loisel bonjour
merci de me recevoir merci d'être venu
jusqu'ici ça me fait très plaisir vous
avez une actualité très riche avec deux
spectacles
un à l'affiche en ce moment et un qui va
arriver très bientôt donc on parlera à
la fin et j'ai envie de faire
connaissance avec vous quel est votre
parcours à quel à quel moment vous êtes
dit vous vous êtes dit je souhaite être
acteur comédien
quand j'étais jeune j'étais déjà fasciné
par le cinéma le théâtre est beaucoup
par les humoristes sur scène le côté
scène me plaisait beaucoup j'ai commencé
à Versailles
on parlera peut-être au versaillé j'ai
commencé dans une troupe d'improvisation
quartier Saint-Louis et après j'ai fait
une école de théâtre et j'ai commencé à
excusez-moi l'impro vous avez fait ça
avec qui c'était une troupe qui
s'appelle le bedding bedingue qui existe
encore le Robert Robert Brideau
qui m'a clairement ouvert les portes qui
vous a fait découvrir ce monde il m'a
fait découvrir la scène le plaisir que
ça pouvait donner il m'a aussi montré
qu'il y avait une certaine rigueur parce
que moi je venais pour faire le clown un
petit peu et c'est un métier c'est un
métier c'est un métier très important et
très difficile mais c'est un métier
effectivement et Robert ouais il a été
il a été génial avec moi et c'est lui
mon premier professeur je pense
j'en ai fait au moins 10 ans avec lui je
pense avoir commencé à mes 6 ans donc
tout petit et après j'ai intégré la
troupe
professionnelle d'un pro du Bedum quand
j'avais 16-17 ans donc
c'est très longtemps réglé d'accord
alors après vous avez enchaîné avec
d'autres cours de théâtre alors j'ai eu
un no man's land de théâtre pendant un
moment où j'en faisais pas beaucoup mais
je commençais à écrire des sketchs dans
mon coin d'accord et c'est qu'après le
bac où je me suis dit allez là je me
lance j'ai fait une petite
alors ceci dit j'ai fait un peu des deux
parce que le ce que j'ai fait ça me
permet d'avoir un diplôme qui me permet
d'enseigner le théâtre et ça me permet
aussi d'avoir des de l'argent de l'État
si je veux monter des projets ou des
spectacles donc c'est un vrai diplôme en
soi et où il y a un examen où il y a des
notes etc mais oui je me suis lancé tout
de suite après d'accord donc vous avez
pris des cours de théâtre au chapiteau
j'ai lu ça dans votre bio
ça a duré un an ah bah j'en ai même on
va parler mais oui j'avais oublié mais
oui j'ai pris des cours de théâtre
chapiteau de Porchefontaine et après
vous avez pris des cours ailleurs
après votre école j'ai fait mon école
j'ai fait
ça c'est Aubervilliers dans les studios
au bout du monde à l'ouest mais bon très
bien pas de problème c'est génial ça a
l'air assez complexe comme formation il
y avait tout j'ai pu toucher au doublage
j'ai pu toucher à la cascade j'ai fait
de la danse alors que moi la danse voilà
c'était pas du tout mais on a appris et
franchement c'était c'était super et la
chance qu'on avait c'était que dans
l'école il y avait des réalisateurs qui
travaillent dans l'école il y avait des
gens qui travaillent aussi le métier de
producteurs et on a pu rencontrer plein
de gens et se faire un carnet d'adresses
évidemment dans les 100 qu'on a
rencontré il y en a peut-être deux qui
vont marcher mais dans les deux et puis
d'avoir j'imagine une vision du métier
oui absolument quoi faire chez qui aller
toquer d'intervenants très intéressants
en plus qui du coup venait
que tu en as pas de quoi c'est pas de
famille quand on n'est pas fils d'eux et
tout ça ça vous a permis de d'avoir les
clés quand même peut-être le pied à
l'étrier carrément et de toucher à plein
de métiers et la chance qu'on avait
aussi c'était qu'on avait des horaires
assez structurés on avait aussi du temps
libre et ça m'a permis pendant ces 3 ans
d'écrire un spectacle avec deux amis ah
d'accord
le premier et c'est là que je me suis
lancé vraiment dans l'écriture avec eux
c'était ça s'appelait triple A c'était
le nom du trio on est un trio
d'humoriste et on a fait un spectacle
qui s'appelle qui s'appelait parce que
maintenant c'est fini première mission
et on avait gagné un concours d'humour
on a fait les tournées enfin j'ai
vraiment pu découvrir ce milieu là à ce
moment là c'était génial et j'ai été
approché grâce à ça par des producteurs
qui ont voulu que j'écrive pour leurs
humoristes ou que j'écrive des pièces de
théâtre etc et donc ça a commencé à me
faire cogiter ce que j'aime mieux écrire
ce que j'aime mieux jouer mais c'était
génial les deux non
aujourd'hui j'essaie de faire les deux
j'ai écrit des spectacles et je joue et
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment c'est
génial c'est très enrichissant parlons
concrètement parlons concrètement donc
là depuis un certain temps un spectacle
que vous avez donc écrit
le coffre à jouer que j'ai écrit avec un
autre auteur qui s'appelle Sacha Radigon
c'est ce que j'allais dire en fait il y
a une équipe de quatre personnes je vois
Auguste lac d'iry Andréa Schmitt et
Sacha Radigon absolument et vous-même et
moi-même et le coffre à jouer alors
c'est le nom du spectacle qui est à
l'affiche au théâtre somnambule à
Montmartre
c'est pas la même chose alors
racontez-moi donc c'est vous dites c'est
écrit par Sacha et moi-même et en fait
on est une équipe de 4 parce que un jour
on va voir un spectacle un beau jour un
beau jour on va voir un spectacle le
spectacle du fameux Auguste ladyrie qui
fait partie des quatre qui s'appelle
Peter Pan on va voir le spectacle parce
que c'était moi mon premier spectacle
pour enfants que j'allais voir et on n'a
pas trouvé ça bon du tout
en sortant c'est dire ah c'est marrant
les acteurs jouent un peu faux les
costumes sont pas très beaux ils
prenaient un peu les enfants pour des
débiles c'était un peu trop instantané
infantilisant donc on s'est dit et si on
montait un spectacle qui nous ferait
plaisir qui prendrait pas les enfants
pour plus bête qu'ils ne sont en
échappant à ses écueils là exactement
bon ça passe un peu à la trappe ce
projet mais un jour Andrea Schmitt nous
dit j'ai un plan pour le Festival
d'Avignon pas cher un petit théâtre 40
places il cherche un spectacle pour
enfants est-ce qu'on le ferait pas on a
envoyé le mail on a tout envoyé on a
créé un visuel en 20 minutes mais on
n'est pas spectacle il n'existe pas du
tout ce spectacle donc le monsieur dit
ah mais c'est génial et de quoi il parle
de spectacle
pas une question on est au téléphone
avec lui tous les quatre on le met en
mute de quoi parle le spectacle on a
improvisé en deux phrases on lui dit on
a dû écrire là-dessus
et l'idée est venue comme ça vous étiez
on a un peu triché on en avait déjà
parlé quand justement après ce fameux
spectacle on avait soumis quelques idées
et celle là nous plaisait plutôt alors
quel était donc vous avez été pris pour
pour Avignon pour Avignon et on a eu un
joli succès Avignon en tout cas on n'a
pas perdu d'argent ce qui est officiel
et plutôt bien surtout qu'on n'avait pas
beaucoup de promotions etc et les gens
il y a eu un très bel accueil et on a
été du coup récupéré par ce théâtre
d'abord au mois de décembre où il y a eu
un très beau succès donc il nous
renouvelle l'expérience à partir du 1er
avril donc du 1er avril pour combien de
temps jusqu'au 21 juin 21 juin trois
fois par semaine et tous les jours
pendant les vacances donc ouais ça va
être une expérience assez intéressante
et vous vous êtes sur scène
alors là pour ce projet là pour j'étais
sur scène pour l'été pour le mois de
décembre je ne laisserai pas
malheureusement pour ces prochains mois
à moins qu'un comédien à un moment donné
un problème c'est pour ça qu'on a
recruté des nouveaux dans l'équipe mais
moi je ne serai pas sur scène je suis
juste à l'écriture là pour là et je
chatte un peu les comédiens aussi les
nouveaux en tout cas d'accord
Digon celui qui avait fait ce si mauvais
spectacle non Auguste l'avait joué il
avait pas écrit le spectacle mais lui il
était plutôt bon ça il était plutôt il
joue le capitaine
pour enfants qui se joue à Paris mais il
y en a beaucoup qui utilisent un peu la
facilité parce que pour enfants entre
guillemets c'est facile de remplir parce
que un enfant va venir avec deux adultes
ou un adulte au moins donc il y a une
facilité à faire un Skoda pour enfants
et au niveau jauge vous voulez dire
économiquement aussi parce que on est
tout seul on raconte une histoire les
enfants ils vont être contents
finalement c'est
combler un enfant au théâtre c'est pas
si compliqué que ça mais du coup on y
vient vite à en faire des choses
ok donc vous vous avez pris le
contre-pied de ce défaut là on essaye en
tout cas j'espère voilà et alors de quoi
est-ce que ça parle alors l'histoire du
spectacle c'est une jeune fille qui doit
quitter sa maison d'enfants pour aller
vivre dans sa vie d'adulte mais elle
décide avant de partir de vider son
coffre à jouets et de montrer les
histoires qu'elle s'inventait avec ses
jouets quand elle était petite quand
elle était petite et la particularité
c'est qu'en fait elle va sortir je vois
deux jouets et le public choisira
qu'elle joue de quel jour ils veulent
voir l'histoire
exactement et c'est eux qui choisissent
le jouet et hop une histoire va en
découler et le ce qu'on a notre metteur
en scène August la guéri a eu une très
belle idée c'est que les cartons de
déménagement selon la manière dont les
déplace ça fait un décor différent ils
sont peints toutes les faces sont peints
etc oui c'est comme des oui c'est des
des cubes c'est des cubes
à une couleur ou un truc un dessin au
début on se dit bon qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire et dès qu'on les réunit ça va
faire un château après on va y revenir
ça va faire un bateau de pirate etc etc
et ça laisse en même temps à
l'imaginaire exactement voilà c'est un
peu minimaliste et c'est pour quel âge
ce spectacle
c'est de 4 à 9 ans d'accord on peut
monter jusqu'à 10 on peut descendre
jusqu'à 3 mais on pense que ça dépendra
de l'intelligence de l'enfant
l'intelligence c'est pas mais je pense
qu'à l'éveil disons il y a peut-être des
dialogues qui ont peut-être pas être
compris ou ça peut être l'ennuyer parce
qu'il y a un peu de dialogue
non ça dure entre 45 et 50 minutes ça
dépend de la folie du public d'accord
oui parce que ça peut être plus ou moins
long du coup ah oui parce qu'on a eu des
publics les publics pour enfants sont
hyper intéressants ils sont très premier
degrés ce qui se passe c'est vrai sur
scène donc quand il y a un méchant
dragon qui va attaquer un château il y a
un méchant dragon donc faut l'attaquer
faut lui crier dessus faut lui dire
battant va-t'en et c'est super
intéressant en revanche si tu es mauvais
tu es mauvais là aussi ça marche pas oui
là si on est mauvais ils vont ils vont
le dire
à part le choix des jouets ouais il y a
beaucoup de moments où ils doivent où
chanter avec nous ou nous aider en
faisant je parle en tapant des mains en
intergissant avec nous donc ouais ouais
on les fait intervenir plusieurs fois
bon super donc en fait ce que vous
espérez c'est que ça soit imaginez un
enfant de 3 ans mais ça se soit son
premier spectacle au théâtre et puis
celui dont il se souvient alors ça c'est
magnifique
le premier jour à Avignon on a eu juste
une maman et son fils donc bon pour
commencer c'est un peu difficile
dans le public d'un public deux
personnes seulement la prendre notre
première date c'est difficile mais on se
dit bon on va le faire quand même le
petit était à fond mais à fond et en
plus il lui inspect pour lui parce qu'on
lui demande ce nom du coup on le disait
comment c'est génial et à la fin il sort
il c'est génial c'est trop bien la maman
dit c'était son premier spectacle et
s'en souviendra toute sa vie on était en
mode
du jeu
et on a envie les enfants qui sont trop
mignons on a envie de d'en prendre trois
avec nous et de les garder avec nous à
la fin du spectacle ils sont trop
mignons c'est non c'est trop bien c'est
une super expérience alors ce spectacle
voilà et je trouve qu'il y en a un
deuxième alors qui va qui est un one man
show alors se lancer parce que c'est pas
comique
parce que ça vient des États-Unis alors
que seul en scène c'est plus
une pièce de théâtre seul si je puis
dire un seul en scène oui ça porte très
bien son nom finalement et alors à côté
moi c'est vous
c'est moi c'est moi
comment il s'appelle ce spectacle alors
il s'appelle premier voyage et en fait
depuis toujours j'ai découvert la
lecture et j'ai aimé la lecture par la
fantaisie par des auteurs comme
Christopher Paolini qui écriragone ça
parlera peut-être des gens tolking et
Cristiano etc etc fantastique voilà
c'est vraiment ça qui m'a fait aimer la
lecture et l'écriture je t'aurais été
passionné par ces par ces univers c'est
monde que les gens créent qui
n'existaient pas mais ils nous est
rentré dedans c'était qui vous embarquez
ouais pour nous c'était sincère c'était
génial et je me suis dit mais
il faut que j'écrive ça il faut que je
réussisse à sortir quelque chose de
fantastique créer votre univers
fantastique
j'ai écrit une frise chronologique et
une histoire il y a quelque chose et en
fait on envoie dans ce spectacle qu'une
infime partie mais j'essaie de créer
tout un monde autour j'espère que les
gens le ressentiront qui a vraiment une
histoire derrière ou pas d'ailleurs
s'ils aiment juste le spectacle tant
mieux et au début j'ai créé au début
c'était elle devait pas être un
spectacle ça doit être une série audio
d'accord une série audio que je voulais
écrire je commence à travailler et j'en
résulte 150 pages
bon je commence à la séparer en épisode
et je me dis mais quand même mon premier
langage c'est la scène il faut que j'en
fasse un spectacle bon j'ai dû faire de
nombreuses coupures parce que le
spectacle pour faire une idée fait 25
pages je pars de 150 mais l'histoire est
la même et l'histoire perdure et donc
l'histoire en question c'est un homme
qui vit dans son village
il fait pas grand chose il travaille en
tant que bûcheron le soir il va boire à
la taverne bon il s'ennuie un peu et un
jour il frôle la mort et il se dit j'ai
failli mourir et j'ai rien fait
et il décide de partir en voyage pour
découvrir le monde et découvrir
notamment un lieu que que son grand-père
qui était un grand voyageur n'avait
jamais vu de sa vie c'est son Graal
alors c'est son Graal quelque chose
comme ça
le lieu du grand-père le lieu du
grand-père qui n'a plus jamais voir et
que lui il veut voir avec ses yeux et
dire à son grand-père qui est parti
aujourd'hui j'ai vu quelque chose que tu
n'as pas vu
d'accord et alors du coup ça dure
combien de temps ce spectacle alors pour
être très honnête au moment
où on fait cette interview
de monter on est on a monté les trois
quarts et on arrive à 50 minutes donc je
pense qu'on va arriver à 1h 1h05
peut-être une heure dix si tout se passe
bien mais voilà on en est là pour
l'instant et on a trouvé le monter avec
le metteur en scène Auguste guéri qui
est aussi présent dans le coffrage le
fameux le fameux Capitaine Crochet qui
est joué dans un spectacle pourri mais
je rigole ouais si pourri
alors du coup vous êtes seul bien
évidemment il y a de la musique comment
comment vous nous emmener dans ces parce
qu'on l'a pas vu évidemment parce qu'il
est pas encore fini alors comment vous
nous emmener dans ces univers
imaginaires vous parlez de la musique il
y a Gabriel Bonneau qui est compositeur
de musique qui a fait une musique
originale pour mon spectacle et donc
qu'on podcast et il a des musiques sur
chaque thème sur chaque lieu sur chaque
endroit et il a réussi vraiment à faire
en sorte que la musique épouse
totalement le lieu donc quand vous allez
être dans une ville portuaire un peu
pirate bah vraiment la musique va s'y
amener Auguste travaille aussi sur les
lumières avec des lumières pour faire
vivre le lieu et l'objectif vraiment
c'est que premier voyage c'est un voyage
donc en l'occurrence que le public
vraiment voyage avec moi à un moment
donné on avait même le projet de mettre
des odeurs dans la salle c'est encore un
projet on sait pas si c'est possible
mais j'adorais qu'au moment où je vois
la mer
ressentent le sel puis quelque chose je
sais pas encore ça va être possible on
essaye mais voilà l'idée c'est vraiment
que les gens voyagent avec nous avec la
lumière la musique mon jeu aussi
j'espère ok génial donc vous passez
quand alors il y a pas de date
7 et 8 avril l'objectif de ces dates
c'est de la présenter évidemment au
public de voir si le concept fonctionne
on l'a fait tester auprès de gens qui
pensent en disent que c'est génial donc
j'espère que ça allait vraiment en tout
cas l'objectif est là de date cette nuit
et voir si le théâtre après je
renouvelle avec eux ou avec d'autres
personnes qui sont qui viennent au
spectacle
et là c'est où c'est au funambule aussi
funambule c'est à Montmartre c'est
arrêt la marque pour ceux qui veulent
plus de précision et alors moi il y a un
truc qui me frappe c'est le le graphisme
des affiches des deux des deux
spectacles d'ailleurs c'est dessiné par
la même personne et non et non mais
première affiche a été fait un petit
côté désuet un petit fais un petit côté
old school totalement totalement je
parlerai de la deuxième après pour le
coffre à jouer en l'occurrence on avait
un premier visuel qu'on avait fait à
laver vite comme je vous ai dit qui
était il nous plaisait beau pour Avignon
et bien mais pas assez pro pas assez
enfant pas assez l'envie de se replonger
dans les jouets de l'enfance et c'est
Cassandre des ombres une graphiste qui
nous a fait cette affiche et on la
trouve ouais on la trouve très belle ça
va désuet mais c'est un petit nostalgie
[Musique]
le côté envie de se replonger dans dans
nos souvenirs d'enfants et alors l'autre
alors l'autre elle me fait penser un peu
je sais pas l'autre elle a un côté je
trouve très bande dessinée mais oui
complètement et elle a été fait par un
artiste qui s'appelle Antoine Humbert
d'ailleurs je vous invite à regarder son
travail notamment sur Instagram il a un
pseudo qui s'appelle Tony au timbre il
fait vraiment un travail assez fabuleux
et quand je lui ai demandé justement de
faire le visuel je savais qu'il allait
vers bande dessinée parce qu'on est tous
les deux passionnés de bande dessinée je
le savais et je le sentais et il nous a
offert ça et moi j'adore elle est
magnifique je la trouve vraiment très
très bien
la dater un peu années 50 années 50
totalement et même on a beaucoup qui
m'ont dit les lettres ressemblent un peu
à au titre de Tintin dans les
commentaires etc et moi j'adore
qui me fait partie des inspirations de
textes pour premier voyage il y a aussi
l'Alchimiste de Paulo qui m'a beaucoup
inspiré pour ce spectacle très bien donc
il y a pas de hasard voilà il n'y a pas
de hasard alors bravo merci beaucoup à
très vite Merci à VOUS plein de succès
sur Loisel et merci d'être venu nous
parler de vos spectacles ça donne très
envie ah bah merci de m'avoir invité à
bientôt Arthur à bientôt au revoir merci
à tous de nous avoir suivis à très
bientôt pour un nouveau VIP
[Musique]